anyway on anyways explain to us what you
do with those massagers how does it work
I'm so curious
wait I want to know now maybe I'm
missing out on I'm gonna yeah yeah it
does alright okay I'll call Hitachi's no
I'm gonna explain it if you would let me
I know the ones they use in porn but you
have different ones that don't look like
they should even be remotely used for
sex at all I know they have two things
and they're gigantic
okay and it has a heavy set yeah I'm
gonna tell you something right now okay
and this is I'm gonna say something very
personal
mhm and something that I thought I was
gonna take to my grave
oh wow okay and I'm gonna share it with
the viewers and Jonna I have a very
complex sexual disposition when I was
young I couldn't get laid at all so I in
between before the ages of 23 I had a
lot of day jobs but what I would do is I
would go to this place called F Street
bookstore which is like a porn place you
know how they have those boots in the
back Oh
sticky floors they do stories and I
would spend hours there every night just
put coins in and truck off because I
couldn't get girls okay that was ugly
okay and nobody wanted me and so when it
was it forced me into doing stand-up
when I was 23 because I'm like I'm never
gonna get laid if I don't do something
that's you know maybe I need something
shiny I you know being on stage is like
jewelry gadget-gadget or being born
looking like Jon Hamm right you you
don't have the talent or looks right
that's at it right so you know I started
getting girls after I doing stand-up um
you still have that it's um you know
that that that old self you know and so
um I jerked off I jerked up a lot in my
20s that's normal no a lot yeah with
your hand right yeah with my hands but a
lot okay
okay and then one day I started with my
hands I just really didn't feel anything
oh here we go here we go yeah we all
right getting real and then what
happened was uh you lookin at you you're
speaking I know but I don't like the way
you're looking at me what I'm saying
this don't look at me you're very
defensive right now nothing very
defensive I'm trying to open I'm trying
to be vulnerable and then my girl was
looking at me like look at this [ __ ]
up piece of [ __ ] that's a some [ __ ] up
I all I asked was to appease my
curiosity I want to hear this story I'm
telling you the [ __ ] story baby I
know but you're attacking me for looking
at right there when you're looking right
that's why I'm so sorry let me turn my
back wait for it okay and then the
second thing happened what I discovered
is there's this thing called you ever
heard of unisom yeah what is that it's a
sleeping medication you get at 7-eleven
or that's or 11 I write it or just
knocks you out right but if you take a
little bit more than the recommended
dosage it makes you extremely horny look
at viagra right but what happens is I
don't know it if you look it up online
it only happens to like one out of every
ten people right but my brother has a
two could release it's the sensation is
insane like your orgasms are 50 times
more insane well and your horniness is
50 times more so then I took of one day
I took a [ __ ] like a like a vibrator
but but wasn't for it was for your back
okay as a gift for like my second year
at MADtv they gave us like Christmas
gifts and one of them was massager and I
had to I was putting on my back and I
was on you know Psalm I was like
wouldn't feel like if I stuck this thing
on my dick and I stuck it on my dick
we're we're placing this on my dick you
like on the shaft on the head well I may
be the first do it you experiment
whatever our eyeballs and your policy
you know and I did my dick and I was
late at night and the orgasm I had tears
okay bad no I'm not your [ __ ] I'm not
[ __ ] tears tears of pure joy you know
mean in my body well I did like my or
yeah I mean like my body was vibrating
right yeah it felt I felt it to the pit
of my stomach and that's what hooked you
so this is why we have if we've ever had
issues with our sex life it's because
he's always wanted to have sex only at
night and only after he's had unisom
because now he always wants to hit this
optimal orgasm and I mean I'm not
kidding you guys like you can tell it's
it's a different type of orgasm because
he does like a spinal jerk it's almost
like a yeah and if you as the spinal
jerking lasts for about a minute
oh yeah so wait for a minute you become
a pop Locker public event yeah it's
really insane Wow and it's a problem my
brother has the same problem see there's
the same thing I'll make his is the guy
I'm I'm I thought I told him about it oh
really Bob
oh yeah four years ago no really one
night he goes go why I need to jerk off
it's not even [ __ ] it for him sleep
so I didn't believe this at first and
then after we talked about it and he
opened up to me because he didn't ever
want to have sex unless he was on unisom
anymore so I looked it up the most
vulnerable I've ever been I've never
said that out loud
it only happens to a very very like
minut percentage of people a very small
percent so very very few people actually
have these effects yeah
the only issue is that he doesn't
realize that he's actually destroying my
liver he's destroying his liver he takes
about nine and nine nine that's
ridiculous she's just a handful reason
why my cat mike-mike war the reason why
my cat have a better gunner it has like
issues now as an adult okay now we're
getting into some real [ __ ] our cat od'd
on unisom
Yunis and you know that's true so we are
cat we woke up and the cat was doing
spinal jerks and like wriggling and then
we had to take he was prompt might have
been having a cat orgasm and then we
took him to a vet okay you do it purpose
what if he came I wonder at me and guna
on the ground it's a minute of heavy
yeah yeah it's a boy cats because he was
gonna die yeah like he I we walked into
the living room and doing this and he
saw all these crush cuz unisom comes in
a gel tab and we saw all these crushed
gel tabs and that's how we figured out
that he had ingested the you know Psalms